وفي الحادث الذي وقع وسط قطاع غزة، كان المقاتلون ينشطون في المنطقة
واجتازت قوات الاحتلال السياج مسافة نحو 600 متر
تعمل على تغطية المنطقة القريبة من مخيم اللاجئين
مارزي في وسط القطاع منتصف الليل بعد الظهر
وكان المقاتلون على استعداد للتفجير باستخدام الألغام المركبة
حيث قام منزلان للدبابة تسالي بتأمين الطاقة في المرحلة
أطلق هذا الكابل صاروخ آر بي جي على الدبابة وهو
وتسببت الإصابة المباشرة في مقتل مقاتلين بصاروخ
وتسبب هجوم آخر شنه الإرهابيون على المبنى
19 مقاتلا يقومون بتفجير الألغام لانهيار المجمع
وسقط المزيد من القتلى جراء إطلاق الأجهزة التخريبية
أن المقاتلين الذين كانوا داخل المباني ينفجرون
ويسبب انفجارا
[موسيقى]
وسرعان ما انهار المبنيان بالكامل وسقط المقاتلون
وفي داخلها معدات يتم توزيعها على شبكة الجزيرة لحظة بلحظة
الانفجار في المرزي من بعيد التقط أحدهم صورة من الجانب
الفلسطيني من انفجار هذا المبنى كما ترى ضروري
إن قول شيء كهذا لاحقًا في التحقيق يجب أن يكون مفهوماً
في سياق النشاط العملياتي لجنود جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
داخل قطاع غزة سواء في الهاني أو من كميات أخرى
إذا كان لديك صور القتال في منطقة مبنية
وهذا ما يحدث هو أن تنظر وترى
تم تدمير جميع المباني بالكامل، كما ترى كل شيء
دمرت بالكامل ومألوفة وتعتقد أنه لا يوجد أحد هناك
ولكن من إرهابيي حماس من يخرج أو يدمر
من الأنفاق أو الاختباء في المنازل المدمرة
إرهابيون فرديون أو فرقة مكونة من ثلاثة أو أربعة
ينظر الإرهابيون ويرون بعض الأنشطة العملياتية
العمليات من قوات الجيش كم من الوقت إذا كان ذلك
بضع ساعات من النشاط تبحث عن الغربان
يقوم المعدون باستدعاء نتائج إطلاق النار على المرضى الآخرين
من أجل المس بجنود الجيش الإسرائيلي، هذا الأمر هو الأنفاق
الهستدروت في المنازل المدمرة التي يبدو أنها دمرت
سيستمر بالتأكيد ويرافق مقاتلي الجيش في الداخل
قطاع غزة مع هذا البخار اليوم بقلم تشن يونس
وينبغي أن يكون مفهوما أن قصتهم هذه هي ميزة
في تسخير المنطقة الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام التي تقول
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو في الجزء المغلق من يشفات
نحن، الحكومة، كنا نتعامل بالفعل مع مسألة كم كل هذا الوقت
من المفترض أن يستمر الوقت في تلك المرحلة الثالثة من القتال
في الشريط مرحلة
وصف
التنظيف في تلك الأماكن التي هي تحت السيطرة بالفعل
كجزء من المرحلة الثانية من المناورة البرية في المدرسة الدينية
الحكومة الأخيرة نتنياهو يعطي الجواب مرة واحدة
الأول دقيق وهو يتحدث عن نصف عام
أقول للسادة الوزراء، كما قلنا مسبقاً، الجزء الجوي
سيكون حملك ثلاثة أسابيع وكان هكذا
وكما قلنا فيما بعد أن كتلة الأرض جزء منها
والثاني سيستمر ثلاثة أشهر وكانت تلك هي المرحلة
أما الهجوم الثالث في شمال قطاع غزة فقد بدأ بالفعل
من المفترض أن يستمر لمدة ستة أشهر، سنضع علامة النجمة هنا
وفي هذا الأمر هناك أماكن لا تزال فيها المرحلة الثالثة
بعيدًا في الجنوب، لم نبدأ بعد
أماكن أبعد إلى الجنوب مثل رفح
بما في ذلك المرحلة الأولى المرحلة الثانية المغفرة
المناورة لم تبدأ بعد، أي نصف عام
إن ما بدأناه في شمال هذا الشريط موجود بالفعل
الأماكن التي لا تزال بعيدة، هل هذا ممكن حقا؟
لتحقيق هدفي الحرب بشكل واقعي
أهمها أسرة حماس وعودة المختطفين
كما تعلمون، قبل يومين قمنا بنشر أميتاي باتريك
كينغسلي رئيس مكتب نيويورك في القدس
تيمز وأنا شهادات أو أقوال أربعة
ضباط كبار جدًا في الجيش يقولون إن ذلك مستحيل
يقولون في الأساس ما يقولونه وأعتقد أكثر
والعديد من النخب العسكرية والأمنية كذلك
دولة إسرائيل السياسية تقول لا فقط
ليس صراحة بالاسم، لكن سمعنا أيضا غادي الزكاة
تقول الفكرة إلى حقيقة أنه لا يوجد احتمال حقيقي
إن تحرير المختطفين من عملية عسكرية أمر لا بد منه
صفقة واتصلوا بي من دوفر تشال وقالوا كيف يمكن ذلك
لكي يقول الضباط هذه الأشياء قلت
بالنسبة لهم أحضروا ضابطًا واحدًا سيضع عينيه عليّ
أو إلى الكاميرا وسيقول أنه من الممكن الحصول على كليهما في نفس الوقت
أعتقد أن الجميع يفهم بالفعل هذه الأهداف
كلا الهدفين مستحيلان وأعتقد أن هناك شكوكا بالفعل
مهم حتى في قمة الجيش، هذا ما قيل لنا
وأيضاً على المستوى السياسي، هل من الممكن حتى الانسحاب؟
أحد هذه الأهداف هو ما إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا حقًا
تحقيق قرار حماس في إطار زمني معقول
يجب أن يكون هناك ظل في الشريط بقدر الضرورة
اجبروه عسكريا فترجعون للجميع
أحد الأسئلة ولكنك تقول أن هناك أيضًا خللًا منطقيًا
بين الهدفين لأنك إذا أردت الوصول
لاتفاق مع حماس على إعادة الشواطئ ثم الاتفاق
وهذا سيتطلب بالضرورة الفرضيات وليس أنت
ميتو، بعد كل شيء، يتحدثون باستمرار عن حقيقة أنه كان مجرد ضغط
الجيش سيجلب السنوار للتوصل إلى اتفاق غير مؤكد
إن صحة هذه المعادلة ليس مؤكدا على الإطلاق
صحيح، ولكن دعنا نقول نعم، هذا في الواقع ما يقولونه
يقولون أنه عليك الموافقة على الصفقة في النهاية
وهذه الصفقة برأيي لن يوافق عليها السنوار
إذا كان الأمر كذلك، فسوف يشمل ذلك وقفًا كاملاً لإطلاق النار والانسحاب
هي أم الهزيمة ومن تسبب في هذه الهزيمة
إنها ليست حماس، وليست أميركية، وليست مثل أي دولة أخرى
جميع أنواع القيود الخارجية، هذا وذاك
وفقط التقاليد الإسرائيلية من اليسار واليمين
كواحدة منهن، فهي تتمحور حول شجاعتها وشجاعتها، وأنا أقول لك ذلك
لماذا لأن معنى النصر كما عرفته
ونفس الشيء الآن يعني الغزو والترحيل والاستيطان
ولقد كنت أقول هذا لمدة 100 يوم 100 يوم
منذ اللحظة الأولى لا يوجد معنى آخر للانتصار ضد
مثل هذا الوضع هو أكثر من مجرد تحويل غزة إلى جزيرة
العبرية كما حولنا عسقلان إلى أشدود وأنت أيضًا
رمات أبيب عام 48 ليس لها معنى آخر للنصر
باستثناء الانقلاب الكامل على كل قواعد اللعبة والحذف
كل عربات اتفاق أوسلو إلا المعنى
هذا النوع من النصر هو
س: الطبقة القيادية بأكملها
الإسرائيلي
والتي نمت إلى المناصب الرئيسية في المجتمع الإسرائيلي في 3
السنوات القليلة الماضية من العبودية الكاملة للمناصب
أوسلو تعود إلى الوطن
و